The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so kinetics we're
continuing with today.
We talked on Wednesday about
first order kinetics and we'll
do a brief review
of some of that.
And we're going to talk about
second order kinetics.
Today we're going to come back
up and talk about chemical
equilibrium, which is something
I love to do to
review things that we've
talked about before.
And we're going to start in on
reaction mechanisms. So, I
thought I would mention, some of
you have may have seen the
activity in the Infinite
Corridor, but today is world
AIDS day, and today a lot of the
compounds that are being
used to treat HIV were actually
designed based on
making inhibitors to enzymes.
And so, to design those
pharmaceuticals, people had to
understand the reaction
mechanism of the enzyme, and
enzymes, of course, are
catalysts in the body.
So, knowledge of what medical
individuals needed to know to
design these inhibitors to treat
HIV are actually a lot
from this unit that we're going
to be talking about.
So, we'll be talking about
reaction mechanisms, and we're
also going to be talking about
enzyme catalysis, which were
key points in being able to
come up with some of the
current treatments
against HIV.
All right, so just a little
review from last Wednesday.
We talked about first
order half life.
We talked about first order
kinetics, we came up with an
integrated first order
rate law, and we also
talked about half life.
And you told me last time that
an example of first order half
life is radioactivity, which
we're going to be talking
about today.
So, just a little review from
last time, you have your first
order integrated rate law, and
the half life is defined as
the time it takes for half of
the original material to go
away, and half life is
abbreviated t 1/2, that's the
symbol for half life, so the
time for half of the original
material to go away.
If you plug original material
divided by 2 in there, then
the original material a to the
o for original, drops out and
you come up with this equation
of the natural log of 1/2
equals minus k t 1/2,
and k is, of
course, our rate constant.
And so, then we can take the
natural log of a 1/2 and we
get a value.
Rearranging that, you get
half life equals 0 .
6 9 3 1 over k.
And so you told me last time for
this plot for first order
half life, each half life,
half of the original
material goes away.
So, one example of a first order
half life process is
radioactive decay.
And the reason why this is a
first order process is because
the decay of the nucleus is
independent of the number of
surrounding nuclei that
has been decayed.
So it's independent of
the original starting
concentration, and since it's
independent, notice that's a
blank in your notes, since it's
independent, then that
makes it a first
order process.
So, we can apply first order
integrated rate laws to
radioactive decay.
So here were some of the
equations we had last time.
We had, this is a different
expression of the first order
rate law where the material,
concentration material of
material a, at some particular
time equals the original
concentration, e to the minus k
t, where you have your rate
constant and the time that has
elapsed, and we also just
talked about first order half
lifes with this equation here.
So, we can use those same
equations, but often you don't
see it in terms of concentration
of a, you
usually see these expressions in
terms of either the number
of nuclei or a different a,
which is a for activity.
So instead of concentration,
we're talking about the number
of nuclei that have decay
or capital N.
So, we can write this same
expression, but now using N
instead of concentration of a,
same thing, number of nuclei
equal the original number of
nuclei, e, to the minus k t,
where k is our rate constant,
or in this case decay
constant, and t is time.
So, with chemical kinetics,
we're usually talking about
the change in concentration of
things over time, but with
nuclear kinetics, we're talking
about the number of
decay events, the number of
nuclei that have decayed.
And so, here with nuclear
kinetics, we measure these
events using a Geiger counter.
So this can measure radiation,
and I'm going to come around
and just check the room.
And so, the gasket's ionized
and then you
hear different clicks.
See if you can hear the clicks
as I come around.
So let's just see if we have
any problems over here.
Oh, maybe a little bit.
No, this is fine.
There's always a little bit of
radioactivity, it's all fine.
So, this is a Geiger counter,
which will measure nuclear
kinetics, it will measure
radioactivity.
And my lab has this particular
one, because we use x-rays in
our experiments.
OK, we'll leave this on low
just to check things
out as we go along.
All right, so we do have
a term, A, that we talk
about in this unit.
Instead of concentration
of A, it's activity.
And so, activity here, sort of
the decay rate, is also called
activity, capital A, and so this
is equal to the change in
the number of nuclei or our
decay constant times the
number of nuclei.
And people will often talk
about the activity of
particular radioactive
compounds.
So, because activity is
proportional to the number of
nuclei, you can also take this
expression and write it as
this expression.
So you can have either the
number of nuclei equal the
original number of nuclei, e to
the k t, or you can do it
in terms of activity -- that the
activity at some time is
equal to the original activity,
e to the minus k t.
So, all of these equations can
be re-written in this way.
So, let's talk a minute
about units.
All right, so the activity for
units, the new activity is Bq,
Becquerel. and that,
actually is named
after a French person.
Henry was his first name,
and my French
pronunciation is not very good.
This is the current unit.
It's equal to one radioactive
disintegration per second.
The older unit, which you may
be familiar with, is called
the Curie, and that is 3 .
7 times 10 to the 10
disintegrations per second.
Does anyone want to guess,
the Curie unit, who
that was named after?
STUDENT: Marie Curie?
PROFESSOR: No, it was named
after her husband actually,
Pierre Curie.
And I actually always assume,
because Marie is actually more
famous than her husband.
But she, Marie Curie won two
Nobel prizes, so we shouldn't
feel too sorry for her.
Her husband shared the first
Nobel Prize with her in, I
think it was 1903, but then in
1906 he was killed in a road
accident, run over by something
that was crossing
the street.
So he did not share the second
Nobel Prize, because by the
time that came around about
1911, he had passed away.
So, at first, we had the Curie,
but then that turned
out to be a really big number.
And so, when you were talking
about sort of safe units for
workers to be exposed to, if
they were being exposed to
things 10 to the 10, that really
isn't very healthy.
So they wanted to have sort
of a much smaller unit.
And so I guess that Marie Curie
at that point talked
about how her husband would feel
about having the Curie
not being the standard unit,
but I guess she was OK with
it, because if we had kept that
same unit, then people
would have been using it and it
would of had to of been a
really, really small number,
because it was sort of picked
to be set up to something that
was too large, and she didn't
want her husband's name
apparently associated with a
sort of an infinitesimally small
quantity of something.
So, the Curie was sort
of done away with.
And Henry Becquerel, who was
one of the people who
discovered radioactivity and
shared that first Nobel Prize,
had the unit named after him.
And I always ask the freshman
chemistry class that as they
go through MIT, if they ever
discover a unit that is named
after a female scientist,
to please come
back and let me know.
This was the one I thought
was named after a female
scientist, but as it
turns out, it was
actually Pierre Curie.
So, if you hear of any,
please let me
know for future reference.
So, the current unit you'll
be using is Bq here for
radioactivity.
So, you're not responsible for
knowing all the different
types of radioactivity.
When you're working problems,
you can always get this
information.
I'll just mention that a number
of different kinds of
radioactivity, some involve
a mass change, some do not
involve a mass change.
So, alpha decay, this isn't
actually in your notes,
there's a reference to
where the table is.
You're not responsible for
memorizing it, so I didn't put
it in the notes.
An alpha decay is equivalent to
a helium 4 nucleus, so you
lose two protons,
two neutrons, so
that's a big mass change.
Whereas say a beta decay
involves a loss of electrons,
so there's no mass change
associated with that.
So just to be aware that there
are these differences in
different types of radiation.
There's also really big
differences in terms of half
lives of radioactive isotopes,
and again, this information
would be given to you on a test
or a problem-set, so you
don't have to memorize it.
So, this table is similar to
one in your book, and the
point here is just how different
half lifes can be.
So the abbreviation a here
is year, d is day.
So you see some of these half
lifes are in multiple years,
some of them are days, so there
are big differences in
terms of the half life of some
of these radioactive isotopes.
Some of them stay around
for a really, really,
really, really long time.
So, I thought I would share
with you a poem about half
lifes today.
And this was written by a former
graduate student at
MIT, Mala Radhakrishnan, and
she is now a professor at
Wellesley college right here in
Wellesley, Massachusetts.
So, her poem entitled "Days of
our half lives," is from her
collection of chemistry poetry,
"Chemistry for the
Couch Potato." And this
particular poem involves the
uranium 238 decay series.
So, here we go.
"Days of our half lives.
My dearest love, I writing
you to tell you all
that I've been through.
I've changed my whole identity,
but loved, I can not
pretend to be.
When I was uranium 238, you
were on my case to start
losing weight.
For 5 billion years I'd hoped
and I prayed, and finally I
had an alpha decay.
Two protons, two neutrons went
right out the door, and now I
was thorium 234.
But my nucleus was still unfit
for your eyes, not positive
enough for it's large size.
But this time my half life was
really not very long, because
my will to change was
quite strong.
It took just a month, not even
a millennium, to beta decay
into protactinium.
But you still rejected
me right off the bat,
protactinium, who's
heard of that?
So, beta decay, I did much more
to become uranium 234.
Myself again, but a new isotope,
you still weren't
satisfied, but I
still had hope.
Three alpha decays, it was hard,
but I stayed on through
thorium, through radium,
and then radon.
I thought I would finally please
you, my mass was a
healthy 222, but you said,
although I like your mass, I
do not want to be with
a noble gas.
You had a point, I wasn't
reactive, so in order to
please you, I stayed
proactive.
A few days later I found you
and said, two more alpha
decays and now I am lead.
You shook your head, you
were not too keen on my
mass number of 214.
I had a bad experience with that
mass before, an unstable
acitone walked right
out the door.
So in order to change, I went
away, but all I could do was
just beta decay.
My hopes and my dreams started
to go under, because beta
decays don't change
a mass number.
To bismuth, then polonium, I
hoped and I beckoned, my half
life was 164 micro seconds.
And then finally I alpha decayed
and then I was lead
with the prize worthy
mass of 210.
I've got to admit I was getting
quite tired, my
patience with you had
nearly expired.
You were more demanding than
any I dated, and much of my
energy had already
been liberated.
But you still weren't happy,
but you had a fix, I really
like the number of 206, So I
waited for years until the
day, which began with another
beta decay, and then one more,
and finally in the
end I alpha-ed to
lead 206, my friend.
To change any further I wouldn't
be able, no longer
active, but happily stable.
It took me billions of years
to do, and look how I've
changed and all just for you.
And wait, what did you say?
You've gotten so old that
I'd rather be with a
young lass of gold?
Well, I give up, we're
through, my pumpkin.
Shouldn't all my effort be
counting for something?
Well, you won't be able to rule
me any more, because I'm
leaving you, not for
one atom, but four.
That's right, when you were
away defusing, I met some
chlorines that I found
quite amusing.
So we're going to form lead c l
4, and you won't be hearing
from me any more.
See, over the years I've grown
quite wise, I've learned that
love is about compromise.
You still have half of your half
lives to live, so now you
go out there, it's your
turn to give."
And that is "The days of our
half lives." So, Mala takes
great effort to make sure that
all her poetry not only
rhymes, but it is chemically
correct.
So, it's a good way to review
material to read "Chemistry
from the Couch Potato."
All right, so let's do an
example now and think about
how things will change
over time.
So we have an example, we want
to know the original activity,
and the activity after 17 years
of a sample of plutonium.
So let's take a look at how
we'll do this problem.
So first, given the information
up there, the
first thing we want
to do is find the
original number of nuclei.
So first, capital N o, the
So, we're given information
about grams, so we have 0 .
5 grams. And now if we want to
know the number of nuclei,
what's the first thing
I have to do?
Convert from grams to what?
STUDENT: Moles.
PROFESSOR: Moles, right.
And here we want to use the
molecular mass that's given to
us in the form of
that isotope.
So here, we are given
information about 239, and so
that's the number we want to
use in our conversions.
So we can convert that over,
but that's going to give us
moles, so how do we go from
moles to molecules?
Avagadro's number, 6.022
times 10 to the 23.
This time we're going to talk
about it in terms of nuclei
per mole, and so that's going
to give us 1.3 times
10 to the 21 nuclei.
OK, so now we know the original
number of nuclei.
The next thing we're going
to want to do is find k.
And k is our rate constant for
decay or our decay constant.
So what do we know about k for
a first order process?
We know the equation for what?
For first order half
life, right.
So that's o .
6 9 3 1 over t 1/2.
And in this problem we were
given, the half life, and
often you will be given the half
life or you can look it
up, and so we can put that
in, so we have 0 .
6 9 3 1 over 7 .
6 times 10 to the 11 seconds.
And we can calculate our
constant, which is 9 .
1 times 10 to the minus
13 per second.
So now we were asked to find the
original activity and the
activity after 17 years.
So, first we'll find the
original activity, and the
original activity is going to be
equal to our rate constant
times our original
number of nuclei.
So we've just solved for both of
these, so we can plug these
in, so we had 9 .
1 times 10 the minus 13 per
second times the number of
nuclei, 1 .
3 times 10 to the 21
nuclei, equals 1 .
2 times 10 to the 9, and what
are the units here?
It's just like a hum, it's
hard to understand.
STUDENT: Nuclei per second.
PROFESSOR: Nuclei per second,
which is the same as what?
That's equal to something
else.
Yup, so that's the same as the
Becquerel or the Bq, so it's
defined as nuclei per second,
or number of disintegrations
per second.
All right, so let's
do the last one.
OK, so now after 17 years, so
now we can say that the
activity at some time is equal
to the original activity, e to
the minus k t, and we can put
in the activity that we just
found, which is 1 .
2 times 10 to the 9 Bq, times e
to the minus k, which is 9 .
1 times 10 to the minus 13 per
second times 17 years, which
in seconds is 5 .
4 times 10 to the 8 second.
So here, we want to make sure
that our units are going to
cancel, and this is where
people often run into
problems. They'll plug in 17
years, and then a rate
constant, which was calculated
in seconds, and things will
not cancel appropriately.
So make sure that you get your
units consistent so that your
seconds are going to cancel.
And so this term, if we do the
math out here with the number
significant figures, we find
that that equals 1.2
times 10 to 9 Bq.
That term is insignificant
in our problem.
So, the original radioactivity
and the activity after 17
years are the same in terms of
the significant figures.
And so, I choose this problem to
emphasize a problem that we
have, and that is radioactive
waste.
It takes a very long time for
some compounds to decay.
And so you have to think about
storing radioactive waste, and
think about a container
that will outlast
that radioactive waste.
And how do you know that the
container is going to outlast
the radioactive waste.
You can't really do an
experiment because the time
involved in doing the
experiment, anyone who designs
the container won't be alive by
the time you're concerned
about whether the container is
going to be stable or not.
So taking radioactivity
is an issue.
You heard some in the
presidential campaign about
whether both candidates believe
in nuclear energy or
not, and I think that both of
them said, it needs to be
considered, we need to have
everything on the table.
If we're going to have a real
uniform energy policy, we need
to think about everything.
So, issues of radioactive
waste and how to handle
radioactivity safely are going
to come back as being current,
important topics.
And so these may be topics
that you will, in your
lifetime, have to deal with,
either as a scientist trying
to come up with new
technologies, or as a citizen
deciding whether having a
radioactive plant in your
hometown is a good
idea or not.
A lot of people are happy about
nuclear energy, as long
as the power plants are nowhere
located near them.
But, these are things that
you'll have to face, and you
probably will be voting on this
in the future, if not
dealing with it directly.
So that's how you do
a problem in this.
All right, so let's talk
about a medical use of
radioactivity.
Radioactivity can definitely
be our friend, as well as
something to be concerned
about.
And I think I mentioned this in
the first day of class, one
of the ways that the Chemistry
Department has moved to being
the number one ranked Chemistry
Department of U.S.
News and World Report over the
years, is a little extra money
that came in from the work of
-- a patent from Professor
Alan Davidson that we were
able to do some pretty
exciting things with that
money over the years.
So I always like to mention
all the great money-making
discoveries that occurred using
511-1 material, and this
is another example.
So, he used an isotope of
technetium, and it's being
used organ scanning, bone scans,
it's one of the leading
ones for heart imaging.
It's also been used recently
in breast cancer.
It's estimated 7 million uses
annually in the U.S. And so,
this was patented as cardiolite,
and it's really
just very simple chemistry.
So you're using a d block metal,
an isotope of a d block
metal, which has your
exciting d orbitals.
And what did he do, he made a
coordination complex with that
metal, an isotope of it, and
he found ligands, cyanide
ligands, those are pretty
common ligands.
You've seen a lot of
coordination complexes with
cyanide ligands, and he tried
different ligands to get the
desired properties of stability
and solubility, and
that's all it was.
So he used some knowledge of
radioactivity, knowledge of
inorganic chemistry -- he was
an inorganic chemist, he's
retired now.
And simple coordination
chemistry, and made an
enormous amount of money for
MIT, and particularly, the
Chemistry Department,
and also, this has
saved a lot of lives.
So, imaging is something
that chemists
do a lot of, actually.
Not just imaging for cancer or
imaging of organs, but also
imaging of live cells to try
to understand how the cell
works when it's healthy.
And so recently, Professor Alice
Ting, in the Chemistry
Department, received an NIH
pioneer award, NIH is National
Institutes of Health, and
started giving these pioneer
awards for people coming up with
very innovative ideas,
the kind of innovative ideas
that most people would not
want to fund, because there's
a good chance it might not
work, but if it did, it
would be spectacular.
So she received one of these
awards for trying to develop
technology to image
protein-protein interactions
in living cells, which is
something that people would
really, really love
to be able to do.
And so she is involved in
developing technology.
So developing of imaging tools
is something that a lot of
chemists do, it's a very popular
area in chemistry.
And if it's something that
you're interested in, there's
definitely a lot of people
around that you could think
about working with for
a UROP position.
OK, so that is first order.
And now let's go on and talk
about second order
integrated rate laws.
And we're going to have a little
derivation for you, I
always like to warn people that
it's coming, because all
of a sudden equations are coming
in and out, and you
just want to know where these
equations are coming from.
So, as we talked about last
time, this is an expression
for rate law.
You have your rate constant,
your concentration of
something, a, and it's raised
to a coefficient, and here
that coefficient is 2,
indicating it's a
second order process.
So if there's nothing
up there, that's 1.
And then 2, and again, the order
of the reaction can be
positive, negative, it can be
integers, it can be fractions.
But this is second order,
so we have 2.
Now, as we did with the first
order expression, we're going
to separate our concentration
terms and our time terms. So
we're going to bring our
concentration term over to one
side, another concentration term
here, and we're going to
have our rate constant and our
time term on the other side.
And now we're going to
integrate, because it is an
integrated rate law.
So we can integrate from the
original concentration of a to
the concentration of a at some
time, t, and then we'll also
integrate from zero time
to that time, t,
on the other side.
Now, I'm going to take this
expression and just bring it
up to the top of the page,
so that's the exact same
expression, nothing
has happened.
And now we're going to
solve that integral.
So we can solve that integral,
and if you want to look at
these -- the back of your
textbook has all of these
conversions, if you want
to look at them.
So, we're going to solve that
integral, now we have minus
parentheses 1 over the
concentration of a at some
time, t, minus 1 over the
original concentration
equals minus k t.
We can get rid of some
of these minus signs.
So we're going to bring the
concentration of time, t, over
on this side, we have our k t,
and now we have this other
term, the original concentration
term is on the
other side, and this is
expressed in a certain way
that gives you the equation
for a straight line.
And again, kinetics, you need
experimental data for
kinetics, and so when you
measure your data, you plot
your data, and so there's a lot
of equations for straight
lines that you have, because
it's all about trying to plot
data, and figure out what the
order is experimentally.
So, here's an equation for a
straight line, and we can plot
this, and you can tell me what
the intercept of this line is.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Yup, so all of you know how to
analyze the equation for a
straight line.
So, here we have 1 over the
original concentration, and
then our slope is equal
to what here? k.
So, you can plot your data as
your concentration of a
changes with time.
You can plot the data, and if
the data, if it's plotted as 1
over the concentration of a
versus time and it gives you a
straight line, that's consistent
with it being a
second order process.
So, in terms of second order
half life, we talked about
first order half life, and for
any half life, it's just the
time it takes for half of the
original material to go away.
So we can rewrite this and
take a to the t, and
substitute in the original
concentration divided by 2,
and then we can have t have a
special name t 1/2, so that's
the half life.
And now we can just simplify
this expression.
We can bring the 2 up here,
and now we can combine our
concentration terms
on the side.
So we take 2, we bring
this over, minus 1.
And that simplifies 1 over the
concentration of the original
material here.
And now we can solve for it
in terms of the half life.
So the half life for a second
order process equals 1 over k
times the original concentration
of the material.
So, a second order half life
depends on the starting
concentration.
So that's very different from
a first order half life
process where concentration
term cancels out entirely.
So for a first order process,
the concentration of the
original material does not
affect the half life, or for
radioactive decay, the original
number of nuclei --
it's independent of how
many nuclei were
around at the time.
But for second order process,
the starting concentration
does matter.
So again, chemistry
is experimental.
And so what you would be doing
in a lab, you would be trying
to figure out what the order of
the reaction is, and so you
could try out your data.
You say I don't know if it's
first or second order, so for
a first order plot, you're
going to be plotting the
natural log of your
concentrations versus time,
and if second order, you plot
1 over the concentration
versus time.
And so you could plot your data
and see that oh, look at
this, it fits a straight line
really well if I plot it as 1
over the concentration.
If I plot it as the natural
log versus time, the data
doesn't fit a straight
line at all.
So this is not a first order
process, this is much more
consistent with a second
order process.
So again, figuring out where
something is first order or
second order is done
experimentally.
All right.
Now we're going to talk
about kinetics
and equilibrium constants.
So, I always get very excited,
as you know, when we come back
to equilibrium constants, so am
always very happy at this
time in the course when we
can relate kinetics and
equilibrium constants.
So, at equilibrium, another
way to think about what's
happening at equilibrium, is
that the rate of the forward
reaction and the rate of the
reverse reaction are equal to
each other.
So, we can now talk about big
letter K, which is our
equilibrium constant again,
and our little letter k's,
which our rate constant.
So the equilibrium constant for
a chemical reaction a plus
b equals c plus d is going to
be equal to what, what do I
put on the top?
Concentration of? c, and
concentration of d, right.
So our products, and at
the bottom we put our
concentration of our reactants,
or a and b.
Now, we can also think about
this reaction in terms of
little rate constants.
So we have small letter k 1 on
top, and small letter k to the
minus 1 on the bottom.
So, the forward reaction, the
rate of forward reaction is
going to be equal to k 1 times
the concentration of a and the
concentration of b.
And on the bottom, our rate is
going to be equal to the
little rate constant, so for the
reverse reaction it's the
reverse rate constant, k minus
1, and in the reverse
direction, our reactants are the
products for the forward
direction, or c and d.
So, here we have these rates,
and at equilibrium, those
rates are going to be equal.
So at equilibrium, little k 1, a
times b is going to be equal
to little k minus 1
times c times d.
And at equilibrium we had c d
over a b is equal to then k 1
over k minus 1, so if we just
rearrange this expression and
move the rate constants to one
side and concentration terms
to the other side, this
expression is the same as this
expression, and we also know
what this expression is equal
to, which is our big K. So,
therefore, our equilibrium
constant equals the rate
constant for the forward
reaction over the rate constant
for the reverse direction.
And so here is an expression
that compares equilibrium
constants with rate constants.
So now, let's think about
what is true about this.
So our equilibrium constant,
then, is the ratio or the
forward rate over the
reverse rate for
these elementary reactions.
And if we think about rate
constants in kinetics terms,
if k is greater than 1, if there
are more products than
reactants at equilibrium,
what's true about k
1 and k minus 1?
Is k 1 greater than or
less than k minus 1?
Right.
So the forward rate constant
is greater than the reverse
rate constant.
And if K, big equilibrium
constant, K is less than 1, if
at equilibrium there are more
reactants than products, what
is true about this
relationship?
It would be less than.
So, you can think about
equilibrium constants now in
terms of rate constants, which
we'll be doing a lot on
Wednesday, too.
All right.
So let me introduce you to a
couple of more terms in the
last few minutes.
So reactions don't usually occur
in one step, but occur
in a series of steps.
Each step is called an
elementary reaction.
So, the overall reaction, the
order and the rate law, can be
derived from the stoichiometry
for an overall reaction, you
can't use the stoichiometry,
but for an elementary
reaction you can.
So, for an elementary reaction,
say one step in the
reaction mechanism, that step
occurs exactly as written so
you can use stoichiometry.
And that's going to be handy in
coming up with mechanisms.
So, let's just look at one
example very briefly.
So here we have the
decomposition of ozone, which
is another environmental issue
that you will be faced with in
your lifetime.
So this is the overall reaction,
and you can't use
the stoiciomery to figure out
the order of the reaction, but
if you divide it up into
elementary reaction steps,
then you can use the stoiciomery
to write the rate
law for each step of
that reaction.
So, the first step here is
a unimolecular step.
You have one thing going to two
things, and molecularity
is the number of reactant
molecules the come together to
form product.
So, unimolecular you just have
one thing that's forming some
kind of product.
What do you think it's called
if you have two
things forming a product?
Bimolecular.
These are good little one or two
point questions on a test,
they're not very hard,
they should be pretty
easy to think about.
So, we have unimolecular,
examples would be some kind of
decomposition or radioactive
decay.
Bimolecular, two reactants
coming
together to form products.
And termolecular is three
reactants coming together to
form a product, and
that's rare.
And you can remember that it's
rare if you think about how
you would hold three tennis
balls in your hand and have
them all come together at the
same time to form product,
that is a difficult
thing to do.
Two things coming together
is easy,
bimolecular is very common.
Termolecular not very common,
that they'd all come together
at the same time to
form a product.
All right, so we can write rate
laws for each step here.
For the first step here, the
rate would be equal to a k --
I don't have the k written up
here, but there's always going
to be a little k
over the arrow.
So, k times the reactant
would be here.
For bimolecular, again,
assume a k over there.
What's that rate going
to be equal to?
OK, let's just take 10
more seconds since
class is almost over.
Yup, so it's this one
right down here.
So we have the rate
is equal to k
times these two reactants.
You can sum up the steps and
get the overall reactants.
Notice that o is an
intermediate, it's formed
here, decayed here.
It goes away, and so o doesn't
appear in the overall
expression.
So we're going to talk
a lot about reaction
intermediates next time.
And also, remember that you
can't prove reaction
mechanisms to be correct,
they're just consistent with
the data that you have.